chapter five chapter five
so we're in the middle now what in the
middle what is now yeah and I think that
we put this chapter here
so we can start to bring forth a concept
of time
um because time is sort of like a map
here it's sort of like a margins or or
guidelines
um
how you feel about this yeah in a sense
uh time is like this ongoing when we
wrote it in the book we said it's the
indefinite continued progress of
existence right
and it's interesting because it's like
it's like something it's like a force
it's an energy it's just endlessly right
right like we always have to attend to
it we have to pay attention to it all
the time it distracts us yeah yeah yeah
um so we want to juxtaposed that are
contrast that yeah time with the
question of what is now and is that time
less yeah and is that I and and again
simple when you think of I is there a
time associated with it is there
somewhere that I needs to be
remember we're not talking about the
person we're talking about I and we're
still investigating what that even is so
so right now as we talk about time we we
can't even mention eye and time in the
same sentence
um but what I will say is that as a
person time can be a prison yes you know
it you have to be here now or there it
it sort of removes you from the Divine
flow or the magical flow of of existence
and it sort of uh dwindles you into this
rigid schedule that you seem to follow
that someone else made in the schedule
is called time right and it's useful for
meeting up with your friend at 2PM for
lunch or whatever
um yet at the same time like Skye said
it can be a prison and it's very
important to ask yourself like we said
is the sense
of I am
I exist
does that have time yeah is there a time
around existence exactly nice yeah and
that one question can take you all the
way to timelessness yes and that is
equivalent to now mm-hmm
and so that's why in five what is now
the more you feel now
which can also feel like an absolute
love for what is hmm
and we're not saying to tolerate
habits
that you no longer identify with it's an
important clarification don't forget the
Power of Choice The Power of Choice
exactly so you can be in total Timeless
love of now and at the same time be
questioning
your choice through investigation and
create more Liberation and more
sovereignty for yourself by sort of
projecting out a star and projecting out
a future projecting out Choice and then
navigating more and more towards that
away from the conditioned habits and so
now and the timelessness can be there's
like a simultaneity of total love
in the in the feeling of exists of pure
existence and at the same time
what do I want like what is Troy like
what do I want what do I want yeah it's
like I'm here now that I'm here what am
I doing yes and how much time do I have
and you have all the time in the world
because I is now
where is I is there is it anywhere else
but here yep
yep and I can answer that because if you
go anywhere you see I
so anywhere has to be here it's great
and here has to be now I love that so I
is everywhere and now and here and we
can just keep doing this Loop over and
over again but yeah
what is now now is I
perfect